imagine ourselves 400 years ago they had
about a 15 percent literacy rate and i
suspect that if you were to talk to
someone who could read back then and ask
them what percentage of the population
do you think is capable of reading they
might have said well maybe 20 25 now you
fast forward 400 years we know that
that's a wildly pessimistic
prediction or assumption that it's
actually 99.99
of the population is capable of reading
well what similar blinders do we have on
today
so i'm excited to have carol dweck here
one of my personal heroes and who's
strongly influenced a lot of work at
khan academy carol
great to have you here pleasure to be
here sal so so what i'd like to start
off with
this word growth mindset which i believe
you came up with
when did you come up with that what was
the motivation and what is it a growth
mindset is when
students believe that their abilities
can be developed
a fixed mindset is when they think i
just have a certain amount and that's it
and this isn't just
kind of feel good talk this is actually
based in science that you actually
the brain actually does grow stronger
neural corrections actually do form when
you struggle in study after study we
have shown that kids who have a growth
mindset
get higher grades it's not a choice
between the outcome and the mindset
it shows that
if kids engage deeply and effectively in
a learning process the grades and test
scores are a natural byproduct
kids who are praised for their
intelligence our research shows
don't want to challenge afterwards
they don't want to work hard on
something
and if they hit difficulty that's it
we find that when
we praise or parents praise the process
the child engages in
their hard work but not just hard work
their strategies their ideas their focus
their perseverance
then
the student learns these are the
ingredients of success if it gets harder
i'll just do these things we've already
done work with you of
inserting growth mindset statements
before
math problems
and we found together that
kids did better so one thing that i hope
is the folks listening to these videos
go out there and tell their parents tell
their children tell their peers tell
their teachers tell their students about
growth mindset tell them that their
brain grows when they get a question
wrong when they struggle when they look
at their errors and they say hey that's
interesting you shouldn't be ashamed of
your mistake you should view that as
something that's interesting something
to explore and when you do that you will
actually physically form neural
connections your brain will actually
grow
you